Arizona governor Katie Hobbs deploying
the National Guard as border operations
in the Tucson sector remain closed to
free up agents dealing with surgent
migrants when it comes to Shoring up the
Border a brand new poll shows the most
favored tactic is more border agents
while about 2third support deporting
those here illegally and penalizing
businesses that hire them our next guest
says that Biden's border policies are to
blame for the crisis Arizona GOP Senate
candidate Carrie Lake joins us now
Carrie so great to have you and so
you're seeing Carrie first of all you
ran when you ran against Katie Hobbs for
that Governor ship your signature issue
was I'm going to send the national guard
down there and now she's reacting to
basically the Border collapsing um
what's your reaction to her now saying
oh yeah maybe we should send the
National
Guard it's it's laughable I mean she on
on week one month one started pulling
down the barrier that that Governor
Ducey put up at the border and while it
wasn't a permanent barrier it was
something and her first Move On the
Border was to tear that down and open it
up I mean this is this is laughable my
plan was to call it an invasion on day
one send our troops down there and stop
people from crossing over the Border in
Arizona and now that the election is you
know uh not too far away we're we're
within a year of the election the
Democrats are in a panic I mean Joe
Biden Ruben gyo Kier Cinema created this
problem everybody knows we had a secure
border under President Trump and they
peeled back all of those policies that
were working Rachel and now we have uh
people tens of thousands of people
pouring across Arizona's border each
week and they're running into our
interior and being busted everywhere
across this country and now she sends
the uh the guard down there and and then
she wants them to just process people we
need to stop people from coming across
immediately and we need to build the
wall and that's the fastest cheapest way
to do it yeah you always hear this we we
we're going to get more money for border
security and it just means more money to
process them so they can get them out
and into the country and not you know in
spaces where the media can come and pay
attention to you know people collecting
under a bridge or wherever or you know
overflowing centers near the border so
we just came up with some polls that
just came out um in the last hour and
they showed that border immigr ation um
and border security the just over a one-
month period jumped seven points in
terms of what people care about in the
upcoming election so I wonder um do you
think it's the polls that are are
causing Katie Hobbs to go oh my gosh we
got to send the national guard down
there and what exactly will the National
Guard do under her
leadership well it sounds like they're
going to be taking some of the pressure
off border patrol agents uh and
processing people and I'm sure that the
members of the National Guard would
rather go down there and stop people
from coming over and then that will
allow us to open up uh some of the legal
ports of Entry I mean so typical of the
Democrat leadership or lack of
leadership to close down legal ports of
Entry to Legal business and legal
tourism so that they can take all of our
border patrol and have them processing
people coming illegal it's just it it
doesn't make any sense and so I don't
know what her plans are all I know is
that it's a bunch of dead end uh deal
for the American people and I'm not
surprised that Rachel the the issue of
the Border has climbed because it
affects everybody we're worried now
about a terrorist attack we heard that
there were IEDs or at least the elements
to make IEDs that were detected at the
border we have fighting AE men we're
importing a foreign army and it won't
take long for people to turn on us
meanwhile our economy is hurting these
people have to be put up they have to be
put up in housing housing that our own
citizens don't have access to and jobs
that are going to be taken from American
citizens it's a mess it's easy to fix on
day one uh you get in there and you
start constructing that wall and then
you start following the laws that are on
the books and we wouldn't have this
problem well you're running against uh
gagos in Arizona you may have a third
candidate Christen Cinema may enter in
as an independent candidate I'm sure the
border is going to be a top issue you've
certainly been strong and preent on what
needed to happen from day one on ktie
Hobs watch and didn't happen until
basically the Border collapsed so um you
probably have a good like to stand on on
that issue for sure uh we'll be watching
this race it's very important um not
just for the Border communities that are
suffering in Arizona but really as you
mentioned it's a national issue and a
national security issue uh car Lake
you've been a very clear on this and we
appreciate you joining us this morning
thank you so much Rachel all right merry
Christmas I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme
and I'm Angley Airhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis